One of the main arguments that we get
from our Muslim friends about why we
should believe the Quran is that the
Quran issues an amazing challenge that
if we don't find all kinds of
contradictions and discrepancies in the
Quran, we should admit that it's from
God. Let's look at Surah 4:82 and I'll
read four translations so everyone gets
the idea.
From the study Quran we have, "Do they
not contemplate the Quran? Had it been
from other than God, they would surely
have found much discrepancy therein."
Ysef Ali, do they not consider the Quran
with care? Had it been from other than
God, they would surely have found
therein much discrepancy.
Hlean,
do they not then consider the Quran
carefully? Had it been from other than
Allah, they would surely have found
therein much contradictions.
And Arbury, what do they not ponder the
Quran? If it had been from other than
God, surely they would have found in it
much inconsistency.
I'm here with uh my friend Ali,
ex-Muslim.
Do you think this is a good argument for
Islam? Well, I mean it's uh the verse is
telling you uh much contradiction. So
obviously the author is not convinced
that he doesn't have contradiction. And
right there there is a problem. If it
says no contradiction, I would say at
least the author is certain that
everything is perfect. But here is like
kind of like leaving the door open for
the contradiction that you are going to
discover, you know. Yeah. I'm sure Allah
had you in mind when he did this.
>> Little [laughter] contradictions is
okay, right?
>> Yeah. So, so what is little? Define
little to me. I mean, that's where they
go.
>> Two, three.
>> It's like, hey, I found 50. Well, it's
not 100. Okay, now I found 100. Well,
it's not 200, so it's not really not all
that much. So, uh, yeah, that's kind of
a weird issue. The other weird issue is
um that this would mean that any book
that doesn't contain any contradiction
or discrepancy would be the word of God.
So, if I have like a math textbook that
has no contradiction in it, it would
have to be a revelation from God. It
would have to be a book of God. If I
wrote a book that contained nothing but
factual statements that are known to be
true, it would be the word of God
according to this challenge put forth.
And so very very strange kind of
argument. But perhaps the strangest
thing about this claim is that we do
[clears throat] find what I would regard
as much discrepancy, much inconsistency,
much contradiction. And we're going to
look at five different types of Quran
contradictions. There could be many
examples of each type, but we're going
to look at five different kinds of Quran
contradictions.
So, first type, we've got one Quran
verse contradicting another Quran verse.
That's a way to contain contradiction.
This verse says one thing, this other
verse says something different. So
here's an example in surah 2:29 we read
he it is this is Allah he it is who
created for you all that is in the earth
then turned he to the heaven and
fashioned it as seven heavens and he is
knower of all things. So Allah creates
the earth then he turns to the heaven
and fashions it as seven heavens. But we
go to surah 79 27-33 and we read are ye
the harder to create or is the heaven
that he built? He raised the height
thereof and ordered it. So he ordered
the heaven, and he made dark the night
thereof, and he brought forth the mourn
thereof, and after that he spread the
earth, and produced thereof,
and the pasture thereof, and he made
fast the hills, a provision for you, and
for your cattle. Do you see a problem
here?
>> Well, I mean, uh, it's very simple. In
one verse, the first verse that you
looked at, it seemed like Allah started
bottom up. First the earth and then he
got to heaven. Second one, top to
bottom, he started in heaven and went
all the way down to earth and the
details of that as well. So if that's
not a contradiction, I don't know what
you call it. Definitely sounds like a
contradiction to me and that's kind of a
big one. Like it doesn't matter what you
believe. If you believe the earth was
created, then the heaven or if you
believe the heavens were created, then
the earth, whichever one you agree with,
the other one has to be wrong. That's
exactly what we would call a
contradiction
>> because it's very clear in the second
one. Then he moved onto the earth.
>> Absolutely.
>> The second type of Quran contradiction
we have is the Quran contradicting known
reality, things that are known to be
true. And as an example, we have surah
18. I'll start at verse 83, but we're
going to focus on verse 86. But the
passage reads, "They will ask thee of
dul carname. Say, I shall recite unto
you a remembrance of him. Lo, we made
him strong in the land, and gave him
unto everything a road, and he followed
a road, till when he reached the setting
place of the sun. He found it setting in
a muddy spring, and found a people
thereabout. We said, "Oh, dual carnine,
either punish or show them kindness."
Now look at all the problems you have
just in verse 86.
He reached the setting place of the sun.
So there is a place where the sun sets
and when he got there he found the sun
setting in a muddy spring and there are
people who live there.
Now, I'm sure you've run into this, but
when I bring this up to our Muslim
friends, especially the ones who are
convinced of the amazing scientific
accuracy of the Quran, they insist that
all this is saying is that someone
traveled west until he reached some sort
of body of water and he saw the sun
setting and reflecting off the water.
And it's kind of an optical illusion. It
looks like the sun's going into the
water when it's really not. You know,
the Arabic. What do you think about that
response? Well, I mean, uh I'm going to
read uh at least the first uh uh two
clause. Actually, I'm going to read the
whole verse in Arabic and then I'm going
to comment on it in case somebody's
watching and they claim that uh you
David don't know Arabic. Have you heard
this argument before?
>> Yep. Okay. So, let's read in Arabic.
Now, I'm looking at least at four
different translations, but I'm going to
pick like
Ysef Ali and let's see what they say
about the word
kind of like a a hot water of spring,
okay? Or spring water. But but
interestingly enough, look at what
they're saying about this particular
location where he saw the the sun. Uh
when it's sitting down, it goes into
Khan says until when he reached the
setting place of the sun, notice the
setting place of the sun, he found it
sitting in a spring of black muddy
water. I don't know what type of ocean
is this, but it must have been a
miserable ocean that he got to. I mean
it says it's a muddy water.
>> Pretty wild that people live there.
>> Yeah. Pel says till when he reached the
setting place of the sun he found it
sitting in a muddy spring and of course
found people thereabout. Ysef Ali says
until when he reached the setting of the
sun he found it sit in a spring of murky
water. Near it he found a people. So,
how in the world can anyone with the
right mind accept this kind of science
that the sun after it is setting down,
it's literally sitting in a place, a
geographical place, and in this case is
defined as a murky water, muddy spring,
and there are people next to it. My
goodness, man. These are thick skinned
people, that's for sure. Yeah, there's
some serious uh some [laughter]
these are some very strong, sturdy,
hardy people to be to be living in the
place where the where the sun sets. Uh
but again, our Muslim friends will want
to say, "Oh, but what it really means is
see, you know, this is it appeared to
him this way." I have to point out this
is not saying this is not told from dual
carnine's perspective of hey, I was
walking around and here's the way things
looked. This is a law saying that's what
he found. Yeah. Yeah. So this is Allah
describing what he found and Allah says
he found the place where the sun sets
and he found the sun setting in a muddy
pool. But it's interesting because we
have a hadith in Sun and Abu Dud where
there's nothing to do with dul carn
here. It's just Muhammad saying what
happens to the son. So I'll go ahead and
read it. Narrated Abu Dar. This is Sunn
Abu Dad 402. Narrated Abu Dar. I was
sitting behind the messenger of Allah
who was riding a donkey while the sun
was setting. So this is the context. The
sun is setting. He asked, "Do you know
where this sets?" I replied, "Allah and
his apostle know best." He said, "It
sets in a spring of warm water." Ham,
right?
>> Apparently Allah doesn't know best.
>> Apparently Allah doesn't know best. But
this is Muhammad. This is not saying
what someone saw. This is Muhammad
telling one of his companions what
happens to the sun when it sets. It goes
down into a spring of warm water. So
this is an example of the Quran
contradicting known reality. And Muslims
know that this is wrong, which is why
they try to completely misrepresent what
the verse is actually saying. But even
though we have three major problems with
that verse,
there's also the problem that this is
dual carnine, which if you read the
story in surah 18, lines up perfectly
with what's called the Alexander
romance. That this is this is Muhammad
copying the story of Alexander the
Great. But in the Quran, he's a devout
Muslim. Some even say a prophet because
Allah is speaking to him. But he's a
devout Muslim in the Quran. And we know
Alexander the Great was as pagan as a
pagan can possibly be. You cannot be
more of a pagan than Alexander the Great
was. And the Quran represents him as a
devout Muslim, which leads Muslims to
say, "No, it can't be Alexander the
Great. It has to be someone else." And
the Quran is basically forcing them into
these kinds of gymnastics because the
Quran is contradicting known reality and
our Muslim friends know it.
>> Exactly. Third, we have the Quran
contradicting the Bible. And your
average Muslim wouldn't care much if the
Quran's contradicting the Bible. But
there is a serious problem here. So,
tons of things we could point to. I'll
just read Surah 4:1 171.
Oh,
do not exceed the limits in your
religion and do not speak lies against
Allah, but speak the truth. The Messiah,
Issa, son of Miriam, Jesus, son of Mary,
is only an apostle of Allah, and his
word which he communicated to Miam and a
spirit from him. Believe therefore in
Allah and his apostles, and say not
three, desist, it is better for you.
Allah is only one God, far be it from
his glory that he should have a son.
Whatever is in the heavens and whatever
is in the earth is his and Allah is
sufficient for a protector. So lots of
interesting things in that verse but you
clearly have it far be it from his glory
that he should have a son. Allah can't
have a son. This is emphasized a lot in
the Quran. Why is that a problem? Well,
we go to the Bible and at Jesus baptism
in Matthew 3, God says, "This is my
beloved son with whom I am well
pleased." So God from heaven says, "This
is my son with whom I am well pleased."
Now there are lots of people there. How
does anyone know that this is talking
about Jesus?
Well, the verse before it says that the
spirit descended in the form of a dove,
right?
>> To show who's being identified there.
So, what do you have? You have the
father and the holy spirit together
identifying Jesus as
>> the beloved son. And Jesus identified
himself as the son. At his trial in Mark
14, the high priest asks, "Are you the
Messiah, the son of the blessed one?" I
am said Jesus and you will see the son
of man sitting at the right hand of the
mighty one and coming on the clouds of
heaven. So father, son, and holy spirit.
Allah just said don't say three. Father,
son, and holy spirit all identify Jesus
as the son. And it's not just the
trinity that identifies Jesus as the
son. You've got the angel Gabriel who
identifies Jesus as the son. John the
Baptist, a prophet according to Islam,
identifies Jesus as the son. Jesus
apostles, who according to the Quran
were devout Muslims, identify him as the
son. You've got Martha who identifies
Jesus as the son of God. You've got
Roman soldiers who identify Jesus as the
son of God. Even Jesus Jewish enemies
who rejected him, condemned him for
saying that he's the son of God. And
even demons
identify Jesus as the son of God as he's
casting them out. So everyone who could
possibly identify him as the son of God
identifies him as the son of God or at
least acknowledges that he was claiming
to be the son of God. So we have a cloud
of witnesses as to what Jesus identity
is or at the very least what he was
claiming about himself. And then six
centuries later, a caravan trader comes
along and says, "Well, how can you have
a son if you don't doesn't have a wife?
It doesn't make any sense." So, he has
no clue what he's talking about and
contradicts what everyone else says,
what everyone in the first century says
about Jesus. A guy in 7th century Arabia
comes along and says, "Nope, everyone's
wrong. I'm right, even though I
obviously don't know what I'm talking
about." And Muslims are fine with that.
They're saying, "Ha, we're going with
Muhammad. Everyone else is wrong. What's
the problem? Well, the Quran affirms the
inspiration and the preservation and the
authority of the Christian scriptures.
Allah repeatedly says that he's
confirming what we have. He tells us to
judge by the gospel that we have. He
says he's talking about the gospel
that's written down with us. So over and
over again, he affirms our scriptures
and yet contradicts those very
scriptures. So this isn't just the Quran
contradicting itself internally. This is
the Quran saying this is the word of God
and this is the word of God.
They're both affirmed and yet one is
contradicting the other. So we have
those kinds of contradictions.
>> Right?
>> Fourth, we have one version of the Quran
contradicting another version of the
Quran. Did you know there are different
versions of the Quran? Well, I mean, as
you know, you've heard this probably
that there are seven canananical
readings.
>> Oh, I've heard seven. I've heard 10.
I've heard 14.
>> And there's 10. There's 14. But it's
kind of interesting that only mere men
chose this. The Quran itself never
testified about itself being revealed in
two or three or four or any number uh
for that matter. And you you say these
are varants or dialects and and you get
so many opinions about this.
>> Yeah. For years, we were told there's
not one letters difference between any
two Qurans. That was total nonsense. And
this really got exposed when Hatun Ta
showed up to Speaker's Corner with 26
different Arabic Qurans. Not 26
different translations, ladies and
gentlemen. 26 different Arabic Qurans.
And she's pointing to the differences.
And Muslims actually accused her later
on because they couldn't get their minds
around this. They accused her of
printing those Qurans herself. So Hatun
just has a big printing shop and she's
printing up Qurans with all these
differences and so I'm
>> going to ask her to print my future
book.
>> Yeah, she's got her own publishing house
apparently just cranking out Qurans all
the time. Uh but anyway, this eventually
this eventually worked its way up until
Yaserati responded and other people
responded and they had to acknowledge,
yeah, we've got all kinds of differences
in different Qurans. But then the Dawa
guys came back and said, yeah, this just
talking about different dialects,
different dialects. So we pronounce
words a little bit differently with
different dialects of English. show the
Quran that's all there is and of course
then we had to start refuting that and
showing no these are saying different
things sometimes even contradictory
things but let me read surah 11:81 in
two different translations where which
sound like they're saying something
different here so this is the hlean
translation of surah 11:81
>> this is the story of the destruction of
Sodom and so Lot was there it says they
the messengers said, "Oh Lot, verily we
are the messengers from your Lord. They
shall not reach you. So travel with your
family in a part of the night, and let
not any of you look back, but your wife
in parenthesis will remain behind." So
your wife is going to remain behind.
Verily, the punishment which will
afflict them will afflict her.
Indeed morning is their appointed time.
Is not the morning near?
And in the study Quran, same verse
reads, "They said, oh Lot, we are the
envoys of thy Lord.
They shall not reach thee. So set out
with thy family during the night, and
let none of you turn around save thy
wife. Surely that which befalls them
shall befall her? Indeed, the morning
shall be their trrist. Is not the
morning nigh?
All right. So, in one of these
translations, it sounds like Lot's wife
doesn't leave. She stays behind and her
whole family goes out. In the other, it
sounds like they all go out and none of
them turns around to look back except
his wife. So, any idea what's going on
here?
>> Well, I mean, if we were to look at the
Arabic for instance, and as you
mentioned, uh there are different
opinions about how many readings you
have, the seven, the 10, the 14. Uh so
if we were to look for instance at those
10 readings the majority of the readers
about eight of them that includes the
most common reading known as huffs from
Assam that's the common Quran that that
everybody has uh reads the uh verse this
way and I'm going to focus on the
emphasis on the wife.
Okay, so it's in the accusative here.
What does that mean? What it means here
that um your wife will not be with you.
She's going to stay behind. So you're
going to take the family, the rest of
the family, and she will stay behind and
she's going to suffer the same kind of
fate that will suffer Sodom and Gomorrah
in this case or the people of Lot if you
wish. Now there is an and interestingly
enough there is at least minority
reading one of them is like is albezi uh
who read or transmitted from ib cair one
of the readers so the transmitter is
albezi the reader is ibir so albbezi is
equal to hs basically here's what it
says
will say
half
notice two what does that Albzi is
saying the word for his wife is a
nominative. That means she will leave
with them but she will be the one who's
going to turn and look back and she is
going to suffer the same fate. So was it
with them and then she turned around or
looks back and she suffers the fate of
that punishment or was she left behind
and she suffered the fate because she
was still there. Don't tell me it's not
a big deal. It is a big deal.
Grammatically is a big deal. And also
theologically here, uh, did she uh,
basically obey, you know, the commands
about what was going on here? Or did Lot
abandon his wife just because she is a
non-believer? Does that mean a Muslim
man can abandon his wife now, even if
she's in danger of dying as a result of
this? I mean there's so many things that
you can reach and conclusions that you
can draw out of this especially at a
Sharia law level for instance or
grammatical level.
>> So if I'm getting this right the idea is
that there's a textual variant which
changes the case.
>> That's right.
>> And it's either nominative or
accusative. Exactly.
>> But that changes the meaning of except
thy wife. So if it's one, it's all of
you go out except your wife.
>> That's right. And if it's the other,
it's all of you go out and no one looks
back except and no one looks back except
your wife. And so according to one, she
goes out with them, but she looks back.
And according to the other, they all go
out except her. So she doesn't go out.
And therefore, that's a contradiction.
She either went out or she didn't go
out.
>> That's right. And also uh really, let's
ask a question. Which version of this
was preserved in heaven on the preserved
tablets?
Which one of these did Allah know in
advance? Did he know that she's going to
leave or not leave? Or is it just a
guess game? Or if uh Allah knew what was
going on, then why do we have a reading
that contradicts the other? Shouldn't we
just have one common reading and stick
to it? And that's a serious problem
because the new explanation is that all
these read all these different readings,
they all go back to the eternal tablet
and they all complement each other.
Well, guess what? These are you've got
contradictions and these aren't
complenting each other. If you're saying
these all go back to the heavenly
tablet, then the heavenly tablet
contains contradictions.
>> Right? And this brings us to the final
type of Quran contradiction. We have
Quran verses contradicting
abregated Quran verses in the eternal
Quran. What do I mean here? Well, in
Islam, in the Quran, you got the
doctrine of abrogation. Allah can give
one verse and then abrogate that, cancel
it, and give a different verse. But
let's look at some examples. Surah 2
verse 256 says that there is no
compulsion in religion. Surah 9:29 says,
"Fight those who do not believe in
Allah." According to Surah 4:43,
Muslims are allowed to drink alcohol as
long as they don't show up for prayer
drunk. It says, "Oh ye who believe, draw
not near unto prayer when ye are drunken
till ye know that which ye utter." In
other words, don't show up for prayer
until you sober up. That's fine. Then we
go to Surah 5:90, which says, "Muslims
aren't allowed to drink alcohol at all."
says, "Oh you who believe intoxicants,
all kinds of alcoholic drinks, gambling,
also
for seeking luck or decision are an
abomination of shaitan's satan
handiwork." Surah 4:15 tells us that the
penalty for sexual sin is house arrest.
says, "And those of your women who
commit illegal sexual intercourse, take
the evidence of four witnesses from
amongst you against them, and if they
testify, confine them, i.e. women, to
houses until death comes to them or
Allah ordains for them some other way."
Surah 24:2 tells us that the penalty for
sexual sin is 100 lashes. The woman and
the man guilty of illegal sexual
intercourse fogg each of them with a
hundred stripes.
So
here's the issue.
Muslims say this verse abregates that
verse. Okay, that's fine. But they
believe that there is an eternal
heavenly tablet. And on that eternal
heavenly tablet, you've got a verse that
says the penalty for sexual sin is house
arrest. And another verse saying the
penalty for sexual sin is 100 lashes.
>> Right?
>> And a verse that says, "Do they not
contemplate the Quran? Had it been from
other than God, they would surely have
found much discrepancy
therein.
So in the eternal heavenly tablet we
have all the issues we've already
brought up but we also have the issue
that all the abrogated verses and the
verses that abrogate them are all
together in the same book claiming that
there's not much discrepancy or much
contradiction or much inconsistency.
It is indeed uh u not only obvious
contradictions but it's troubling when
you think about it because you have the
author of the Quran himself anticipating
that there's going to be contradictions
but leaving the door wide open as to how
much of the Quran will have that. I mean
so far everything that you've shared and
you mentioned already these are just
samples not everything. It's not an
exhaustive list of them.
>> They've been troubling already.
>> That's right. And so when your Muslim
friends bring up these kinds of um
verses of the Quran making this
challenge, show us where the
inconsistency is. Show us the
contradiction. We gave you five
different types of Quran contradictions.
Can you think of more?
>> [music]
[music]